grosse nouveauté c'est un moniteur
gaming qui est présenté ici en
avant-première au CES à Las Vegas c'est
l'Odyssée Neo G9 alors le truc si vous
voulez jouer vous voulez beaucoup
d'immersion souvent on se met trois
moniteurs et on a les bords qui nous
cassent un peu les bonbons ici vous avez
un moniteur tenez vous bien 57 pouces
avec une résolution dingue on se parle
ici de
7680 pixels par
2160 pixels c'est juste énorme alors je
donne des infos taux de rafraîchissement
de 240 Hertz avec une milliseconde de
latence pour vous dire que si ça envoie
du bois et en plus vous avez pour la
première fois un port display un
DisplayPort 2.1 et on se parle ici d'un
moniteur en quantum mini LED on a de la
miniette c'est juste classe en terme de
luminosité en terme de détails on est
juste dans un truc qui est magnifique
c'est un très gros moniteur qui va être
présenté ici en avant-première au CES
par Samsung tout ça c'est dingue
d'ailleurs dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires